[Music]
we'll talk later in the game about uh or
later in the show about who will win who
we think will win with the spreads
factored in in the afc and nfc
championship games how about some of the
props that have been identified in
advance and these are real props we've
made them up in the past these are real
props that you can bet on if you are in
a state where that sort of of behavior
is now legal largest lead in the rams
saints game largest lead remember the
last time they played at one point the
saints were up by 21. for this game the
over under is 14 and a half chris let me
throw it to you will it be over will it
be under i'm gonna go with under here i
just have a hard time believing that
we'll see any team really pull away to
that you know extent throughout the game
i just think it's a very evenly matched
football teams with two great coaches on
both sides of the ball two very good
defensive coordinators on that side of
the ball i mean i think this is going to
be a nail biter where it's going back
and forth and maybe whoever has the ball
last kind of pulls it out in the end but
i would be shocked if anybody's ever up
by more than 14. yeah i agree with that
one the unders plus money as well so you
might as well take that and i i just do
i mean i could see in a world where the
saints and the dome different team in
the dome yeah they jump on the rams but
i'd agree 14 and a half feels a little
too high i think maybe there'll be a 10
point lead 14 half too high so i'm going
under as well
yeah the under at plus 140 but i could
see a game where yeah there's a big lead
and then it goes away and then there's a
big lead and then it goes away i mean we
saw what the rams could do when they
were down 21 and i think that 14 and a
half is a great spot to put it because i
could see very easily saints up 14 and
then that leads gone and then maybe the
rams are up seven and then it goes the
other way i mean when you're talking
about two high powered offenses that can
move the ball and score points now both
teams maybe were more effective in both
regards earlier in the year but when
they get together on sunday there's a
chance and i think back to that nfc
championship game from 2009 i mean it
was yards and points and scoring the
vikings lost him in the vikings game
that they lost when adrian peterson
right before the game remember that
remember that pressure through that bad
interception when they were in field
goal range you mean that right remember
that game mike he had the french fries
right before the game then he dropped
the ball he put it on the on the floor a
couple times
just let me know when you're done okay
okay please are you done yeah i'm done
uh so i agree with you guys i'll take
this i try to talk myself into the over
but i'll take the under let's move on to
running back with more yards in the nfc
championship game todd gurley or alvin
kamara big cat who you got okay despite
the reports that uh todd gurley is upset
about his touches per game i'm gonna say
todd girl
uh alvin kamara he i mean his rushing
yards have not been like insane the last
i don't know six seven i misspoke i
misspoke i'm sorry more totally no no no
i know i know but i'm sorry you know
it's more interesting the rushing yards
obviously play into the total yards i
think todd gurley will have a big game
and i think sean mcvay knows that if he
wants to keep a happy household he's got
to give todd gurley the ball a bunch
yeah i'm going girly as well here uh
because i i do think not only that like
what big cat's saying but i just think
he's gonna look at it and go you know
gurley's one of our best weapons and if
we're worried about jared goff one of
the best way to get him easy completions
is to throw you know short passes to
gurley out of the backfield the wide the
running back screens awful play action
they're masterful at that and you know i
know he's gonna have to share carries
with cj anderson but i think they're
going to ride their stud here in the nfc
championship game and i look at camara
big cat makes the point yes they don't
usually give him the the kind of touches
to run the ball 18 to 20 times a game he
has to you know share that with ingram a
little bit so i lean gurley on this one
this is one of those where there could
be a little controversy when it's time
to take your ticket back to the window
because when they say total yards do
they mean all-purpose yards because you
got potential kickoff returns
okay yeah i answered the question right
now believe me i think i'm not going to
tell you anytime then i'll go talk to
yeah i'll go todd you've been burned by
that one before oh yeah at the window
there's nothing wrong on the glass
there's nothing more money than
refreshing the page to see if maybe they
got the yardage wrong and maybe you get
you round up from a half a yard
so todd gurley i agree with you even
though cj anderson is gonna get uh more
than a few carries todd gurley will have
some big runs and and i think todd
gurley it tilts in his favor a little
bit more and i think the the rams need
gurley to step up and have a big game
more than the saints need camaro because
they have so many other weapons on that
side of the ball all right let's flip
over to the afc for rob gronkowski over
under receiving yards 51.5
chris what do you have yeah i mean it's
crazy that we're putting that number
that 51.5 for rob gronkowski where we've
just been years and years of going in
big games i mean you know it's like it
didn't seem like 80 would be that number
90 100 it'd be around there i'm going to
take the under here oddly enough i did
not expect to really be saying this but
you know he's just not been a factor in
the past game i mean rob gronkowski's
greatest strength right now is as a run
blocker he's like having an extra
offensive tackle on the field and i
think we saw last week with the way
they're running the football they'll
keep him on situations in to make it
look like the run and then it's you know
edelman behind the second level or a
hogan or whoever it may be uh so and of
course the james white factor out of the
backfield i'm going under with
gronkowski
this is bad because we keep agreeing but
i totally agree rob gronkowski uh his
last six games 25 yards 24 yards 21
yards 107 against miami because they
decided that they'll just put one guy on
him yeah which was insane 26 and 56. so
there's only one of those if you take
out the miami game right where he went
over this yardage number and they're
gonna run the ball like you said so rob
gronkowski as a blocker is more valuable
to the patriots right now than going out
there and catching past yes
the last big moment we saw from rob
gronkowski this year other than his
effort to try to make the tackle at the
end of the dolphins game the big moment
that is seared into our brains was that
catch he made down the field that
allowed the patriots to win against the
chiefs back in week six and i think
gronkowski and he was waxing kind of
poetically about what it means to be in
eighth street afc championship games and
if he really is moving toward the end if
this is his final year i could see gronk
step up and have a significant game and
i could see the patriots unleash him in
a way that maybe they haven't in recent
weeks and maybe it's been a long con
right maybe it's been a multi-week
rope-a-dope with this game being the
thing that they were setting the chiefs
up for because the chiefs look at gronk
over the last seven weeks and say ah we
don't have to worry about gronk and then
here comes gronk and he explodes in a
big way i'm taking the over it's minus
135 for the under i want the over guys
especially since uh we can't all agree
about everything well yeah i say he's
gonna have at least 75 receiving yards
if the chiefs leave you know no names
like number 30 on them all game then
then me and big cat are going to be in
big trouble uh certainly but uh yeah
okay you're taking the over good for you
longest touchdown in patriots chiefs
over under
45.5 yards big cat a throw to you this
is one of those uh bets that it's my gut
versus my head because my head says it's
going to be under it's going to be a
little cold they're going to try to run
the ball i think the patriots are going
to try to make patrick mahomes go down
the field 15-yard drives to score right
but
all i'm thinking about is tyreek hill
yeah and so i'm taking the over because
it's the most electric play in sports
and if he gets even a second of space
he's gone yeah right he's maybe the
fastest receiver we've ever seen i'm i
know i'm i don't mean to agree with this
guy so much but i'm going with the over
as well because even if the the patriots
play oh we're gonna play this ben don't
break we're gonna try to keep everybody
in front of you yeah that's great that
sounds good it's great on the chalkboard
and everything but we've seen that it's
only a matter of time before mahomes
gets out of the pocket and throws a
laser down the field like we saw the
first time around or like big cat's
saying he throws the ball down the
middle of the field to tyree kill and he
catches it and he's got a little space
and no one's gonna catch him so i have a
hard time thinking that there won't be
at least one play over that mark in this
game even by me either team because of
course we know the chief's defense is
not exactly the steel curtain
yeah i think you throw tyree killing and
that's the difference maker i think
there's always a chance a good chance of
a touchdown that long but hill is the
guy that we can count on to have that
kind of a play the patriots cannot
contain this guy they were talking
yesterday patrick chung and stephan
gilmore about the different things
they're doing to try to simulate and
mimic him in practice you can't you
can't do it they can't be ready for this
guy they haven't been able to deal with
him they faced him twice he has ripped
them up every time i agree with you guys
there will be a touchdown longer than 45
and a half yards and it's gonna have a
lot to do with the presence of tyree
kill all right one more before we take a
break more combined yards in the game
tom brady and sony michelle or patrick
mahomes and damien williams chris who
you got yeah i was going to say you go
because i'm just going to disagree with
you whatever
spin it yeah no matter what okay fine
all right i'm going to go with my homes
and williams as far as more combined
yards my biggest reason being um
the screen game for damian williams i
think mahomes will have a good i mean my
home's throwing for 300 yards is just
ho-hum at this point i mean like oh you
threw it for 300 we don't even talk
about it anymore where brady and
michelle we talk about the run game but
also i think what hurts michelle maybe a
little bit in this matchup is you know
james white they're going to throw the
ball to james white and run the ball
with michelle where damien williams gets
a little bit of both i'm expecting andy
reid to stay somewhat balanced for andy
reid so i'm going to go mahomes williams
thank you for proving my point for me
chris because you just said they're
gonna run the ball with michelle and
throw the ball to james white guess what
what both of those count for me because
i have brady and michelle so when tom
brady throws it to james white that
counts for me when sony michelle runs
that counts for me you just proved my
point that's a valid point you're right
i mean it does kind of like it's massage
your point but
i would probably say mahomes if i didn't
try to intentionally disagree just
because i think the chief's offense has
to be explosive
i'll break the tie and i i think it will
be brady and michelle i think brady look
for the same reasons gronkowski
understands this the significance of
this moment and brady's heard all the
praise from mahomes all year long he'll
act like he didn't he has this is his
chance to remind everyone that he's
still the greatest of all time maybe
mahomes will get there but for now it's
brady and i think we're going to see him
do some special things and if not
michelle is going to supplement it on
the ground so i'll go brady and michelle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports